- You know most firms would put you
in front of the bar and
have your license stripped.
You lied to a client
and he figured it out.
- Yes, exactly!
Don't lie to a client.
You should not lie to a
client and defraud them.
(upbeat music)
Hey legal eagles, D. James Stone here
teaching you how to think like a lawyer.
Today we're tackling a fan favorite,
highly requested, Suits.
Now I've never seen a full
episode of Suits before
but I'm guessing from the title
that it's about a group
of men who wear suits.
You can tell I'm very
perceptive about these things.
As always if you see any
legal or factual inaccuracies
please leave me a
comment below in the form
of an objection.
If you object I will get
to it and I will either
sustain or overrule your objection.
But let's dig right in,
oh and by the way stick around
until the end of the
episode where I give suits
episode one a grade for legal realism
so you won't wanna miss that.
But without further ado let's dig in
to Suits, episode one.
- First of all Gerald
if you think anyone's
gonna touch this deal
after your bad faith you're mistaken.
Second the way our agreement works
is the minute Cooper signed the deal
which gave you everything you wanted
our fee was due and payable
which is why at 7:30 I
received confirmation
of a wire transfer from escrow
indicating payment in full.
- Wait, is the deal done or not?
No transaction on the planet would have
someone transfer a huge amount of money
before the deal is consummated.
Now, there are companies that
deal in this sort of thing
they're called escrow companies.
If there is an amount that
is going from one company
to another then you give your money
to an escrow company.
They hold it until all the
deal terms are complete
and then they turn it over
when certain criteria are met.
If any lawyer's drafted a
deal that had a wire transfer
going before the terms are complete
that's probably malpractice.
So this is crazy.
I don't know what deal
they're talking about
but that would not happen.
- We got paid before
Gerald signed the deal?
- What are you talking about?
This is a memo about some
fire drill on Tuesday.
You're the blue team captain.
You get to wear a fire hat.
- Okay, alright so what
this person has done
is called fraud.
He has made up facts that are not true
in order to induce someone
to enter into an agreement.
When you induce someone based on fraud
that is called fraud in the inducement,
and when you commit
fraud in the inducement
that deal is null and void
because you fraudulently
got them to enter into a deal.
So, if this deal goes through
and the other guy finds out
that he's been lied to
in a fraudulent manner
that deal is no longer done
and it would be unwound
and the whole thing
would just blow up.
So that's not good lawyering.
Good lawyers don't lie,
good lawyers use the facts as
they exist in the real world
to make sure that all the
parties get their best deal.
They do not lie in order
to consummate a deal.
That is bad lawyering, that is malpractice
and it might be a crime.
- [Teacher] I got it.
- Alright, so he's an LSAT cheater.
And he hid his test so
that no one would know
that he cheated.
- Hey.
Hey stop!
You in the cap.
(intense music)
- This is really interesting.
LSATs or the Law School Entrance Exam
is very important.
Its how you get into a good law school.
It's how you get into any law school.
So it's not surprising then that given
how important the LSAT is
there is some cheating.
Now the board that offers the LSAT
has tried to combat cheating
so they require you to
bring in a drivers license
or other valid form of
ID and they check that
when you enter and when you leave.
But sometimes people get around that.
Given how important it
is it's not surprising
that there are some really
nefarious people out there
who are going to try to game the system
and try and get a good LSAT score
because it can change the
course of your entire career.
(intense music)
- [Man] What did you get me?
- What I said I was gonna get you, a 158.
- I told you I wanted a 175.
- I told you only one
out of a hundred people can score that.
- That's right if you score a 175
that means you're in the 99th percentile.
Actually you're well
into the 99th percentile
of the LSAT.
It's scored from 120 points to 180 points.
So if you score a 175 that means that you
are basically in the 99.5 percentile.
That is very, very high and
so he's not exaggerating
when he says a 175 is only procured
by one out of a hundred people.
And he said he scored a 158.
That's not a great score, that's probably
in the 80th or 85th percentile
so not bad, but certainly not a score
that's going to get you
into one of the top tier
law schools out there.
So it's funny that he's
complaining about the score
that he cheated and got from this guy.
- We need people who think on their feet,
not another clone with a rod up his ass.
- Harvey the fact that
we only hire from Harvard
gives us a cache that's
a little more valuable
than hiring a kid from Rutgers.
- You went to Harvard Law.
- I'm an exception.
- Find me another one.
- Alright so the recruiting process
is a fascinating process in law school
and with firms that I
could talk about for hours.
Suffice it to say there
are firms that only hire
from certain schools.
Now there probably aren't any law firms
that hire only from Harvard.
You're probably gonna
hire from the top five
or the top 10 or the top 20 law schools,
but there are law firms
that are very picky
about where they get their
summer associates from.
Now a summer associate is
a law firm specific term.
It means someone that's in law school,
usually this is someone
who is in their second year of law school,
their second year summer
and they're basically
interning for the firm.
And if you like that person
at the end of the summer
then you'll give them an offer
to come work for the firm
when they graduate from law school.
That's what they're
saying when they're saying
they are looking for a summer associate.
That's a very common thing
for big firms to look for.
So it's cool that they
get that lingo down.
That's absolutely accurate.
- Great thanks.
- Okay.
- Dot, we're gonna need
to streamline this.
Give each guy a hard time
before you send them back,
keep me awake if they say
something clever, cool?
- Okay.
What are you looking for?
- Another me.
- Okay this is great.
He's interviewing the
law students at a hotel
which is exactly where law
students tend to get interviewed
for these, what are called
on campus interviews.
Now I went through the
process in Los Angeles.
I assume the process is
pretty similar in New York.
The law students all enter
their names into a lottery
then you send everyone to a hotel.
You get a bunch of
associates or junior partners
in the law firm to hang
out in a hotel room.
The law students come in and
they conduct their interview.
So, so far that aspect
of the recruiting process
in law school is spot on.
It's so funny, I've never
seen that in a TV show before.
- So Chip, what makes you
think that I'm gonna let
the whitest man that I have ever seen
interview for our firm?
- Because I have an appointment.
(upbeat music)
- And lawyers have all kinds of criteria
as to how they choose
people for callbacks.
These are screening interviews.
They're just going through
dozens, if not hundreds
of law students
and if they like you then
they send you for a callback
where you'll be interviewed
by a bunch of attorneys
at the law firm itself.
So you're really churning
and burning in the hotel
and it's funny that
this guy has a criteria
of they have to say a witty remark.
- If you want this job so much
why don't you just go to law school?
- When I was in college it
was my dream to be a lawyer.
I needed some money
and Trevor convinced me
to memorize this math test and sell it.
Turns out we sold it
to the Dean's daughter.
I lost my scholarship, I got
kicked out of school I...
I got knocked into a different life.
- There's some truth to that.
In law school, and
especially when you're trying
to become a member of the bar
they look at your moral character
and if you have a blemish on it
you're going to have to explain it.
Now, a youthful indiscretion
with no follow up conduct
and no criminal record,
I don't think that's
gonna be a huge barrier
to becoming an attorney.
You will have to explain it to the board
but it shouldn't preclude you
from entering into the
profession for your entire life.
You just have to explain it.
Explain that you're not going
to do something like that again.
- I need a grown goddamn man.
- You give me this and I
will work as hard as it takes
to school those Harvard douches
and become the best
lawyer you have ever seen.
- I'm inclined to give you a shot
but what if I decide to go another way?
- I say that's fair,
but sometimes I like
to hang out with people
who aren't that bright, you know,
just to see how the other half lives.
- Move over, I'm emailing the firm
we just found our next associate.
(upbeat music)
- The problem here is that
he has ethical limitations
as well and if he is
knowingly sort of conspiring
to have someone who's
not a member of the bar
participate in these activities
that is a huge problem both for Mike,
but also for Harvey because he's the one
that's sort of knowingly supporting it
so he may run into ethical issues himself
that might result in him
losing his bar license
by knowingly hiring someone
that isn't an attorney
to do attorney's work.
So big problems there for both of them.
- Gerald Tate fired the firm.
- So you're taking my promotion away?
- You know most firms would
put you in front of the bar
and have your license stripped.
You lied to a client
and he figured it out.
- Yes, exactly!
Don't lie to a client.
You should not lie to a
client and defraud them.
And, oh my God, he's a
client, not the opposite side.
Why would you even lie to your client?
You're not even trying to close
a deal from the other side.
I mean you have an ethical obligation
to do what your client wants
or to get the outcome
that your client wants.
To lie and defraud your
own personal client?
He should be disbarred for that.
That's crazy, don't do that.
Pro tip, don't lie to your client.
- No more shenanigans.
You do one more thing that
isn't straight as an arrow
and instead of covering your ass
I'll put you in front of the bar myself.
- Mike.
- Hey, who's ready for a great first day?
- I'm gonna have to let you go.
- That's probably a good
thing to do at this point.
- For lying to a client
and if they find out
that I lied about you
going to Harvard they'll--
- Oh, and by the way, the
whole partnership model
of a law firm means that the partners
have joint and several liability.
So if one of the partners
conducts some horrible fraud
on their client, the whole
partnership is at risk
at that point.
So, you know, you gotta be really careful
and you have to worry about
what your other partners
are doing, so to cover up for a partner
who is defrauding and
ignoring their own client
to bully them into a
deal, that is not good.
This firm is not going to
exist for very much longer.
- I'll um, I'll give you your promotion,
but you have to do something for me.
- [Harvey] Anything.
- Just digging it deeper.
- Pro bono.
- Anything but that.
- Harvey, pro bono cases
are how we as a firm
show that we care about
more than just ourselves.
- I'm not saying we shouldn't do them,
I'm saying I shouldn't do them.
- And it's how you--
- A lot of lawyers feel that
way about pro bono work.
You generally have an ethical obligation
to do some pro bono work during the year
so you can help those who
can't afford the large fees
that most law firms command.
But that being said some
lawyers really hate doing it.
Some lawyers really like doing it
because you can get experience
that you wouldn't otherwise
be able to procure
like going to trial more often than not
or working one on one with a client.
When you're a junior
associate you often don't get
those opportunities.
But if you're a senior
partner you can understand
why they don't wanna take that away
from their billable practice.
Still, kind of a dick move though.
- One night he says
that if I sleep with him
he's gonna take care of me in the firm
and if I don't he's gonna fire me.
- So what did you do?
- I went to human resources.
They said they investigated,
couldn't find anything
to support my claim.
I wasn't looking for a payoff.
All I wanted was for it to stop.
Can you help me?
- Uh, yes.
Yes, I can.
- So generally speaking
there are two types
of sexual harassment.
There is the hostile work
environment sexual harassment
where by the actions of someone it creates
an environment that is
non-conducive to working
that makes people feel uncomfortable
such that they can't work there,
and you know, that's
generally referred to as
creating a hostile work environment.
You're not allowed to do that.
But the second type of sexual harassment
that is really less common
because it's so much worse
and so much more explicit is
quid pro quo sexual harassment
which is what this person describes
where you are conditioning
a job or a promotion
or some perk on some sexual favor
and it's a really terrible thing.
It definitely happens.
Thankfully it's more
rare than it used to be.
So if that client is to be believed
that is a classic case of quid
pro quo sexual harassment.
Totally illegal, but it's
very hard for victims
of that kind of harassment
to prove what has happened
because it's a classic
case of he said, she said.
- I don't know how to fill out a subpoena.
- Come on genius.
How hard is it to fill out a form?
- Donna, can you show me
how to fill out a subpoena?
- Absolutely, and after that
you want me to show you
how to wipe your ass?
- It's funny because
you should already know
how to do both those things.
- No, no.
No summer associate
would know how to do that
just right off the bat.
Now true, he could look at the form
and he could probably
muddle his way through
but the funny thing about
that is if he files a subpoena
with the court, or sends a
subpoena to the other side
and signs it, he has effectively
pretended to be an attorney
and engaged in the
unauthorized practice of law
which would get basically
all of them disbarred,
especially him.
So everyone there at
that firm has obligation
to make sure that he does it right
and they shouldn't be chastising him
for not knowing how to
fill out a particular form
and in fact for any summer
associate if they fill out
a subpoena or discovery request
then an attorney's gonna have to review it
and sign it and if you sign
that you are basically saying
that it's as good as
if you did it yourself
and it is accurate and
it complies with the law
and you can be sanctioned
as if you wrote it yourself.
You cannot allow a summer associate
to take credit or practice law.
So all their asses are on the line here.
They should not be
chastising him for this act
of filling out a subpoena.
- Okay, I have two words for you.
Absolutely beautiful.
- You think you're the only
one who can charm a client?
- Categorically stunning.
- So what most people don't
know about being a big firm
attorney is that without
clients the firm can't operate.
So generally there are a couple
different types of partners.
One are the partners that
just bill like crazy.
They're often the best attorneys.
They're the ones that
really put in the hours
and they're bringing
revenue into the firm.
Now there's another type of partner
which are the rainmakers,
the people that more focus
on bringing clients in.
Now both of those types
of partners are important
because without clients
there's no work to be done.
So often an attorney's job
is not just the nine to five
court pleadings and
dealing with transactions.
There's a lot of client management
where you have to make sure
that there are more clients coming in
so that you have work to do in the future.
- They filed a motion to dismiss the case
based on our lack of evidence.
- Good.
- Good, what do you mean good?
- They don't wanna hand over the files.
You pressed where it hurt,
you're looking in the right place.
Did you think they wouldn't fight back?
- Well, I...
Now that you mention it.
- Oh.
- Alright, so that doesn't
make any sense at all.
A motion to dismiss is
a motion that you file
on the basis of the pleadings.
So, they're the plaintiff here.
They file what's called a complaint
which lays out their whole story.
That she was fired and
the other side is allowed
to either file an answer
to that or file a motion
to dismiss in most jurisdictions.
The part that doesn't make any sense here
is that the motion to
dismiss takes the allegations
and the complaint at face value.
So there's no evidence at this point.
There's been no opportunity for discovery,
it's also been just a couple of days
so these things take months.
But you can't file a motion to dismiss
on the basis the other side
doesn't have any evidence
because no one has
gathered any evidence yet.
So that doesn't make any sense.
- I care about this woman.
She's got nowhere else to turn--
- And you can't help her by yourself.
- I can, I just prefer not to.
- This is a really good example of why
you would never hire someone
who did not go to law school
and doesn't have any legal experience.
The law and being a lawyer
is all about application.
It's not about the memorization of facts.
I can go online and I can look up
what the rule is, what the law is.
I can look up the case law.
I don't need to have a photographic memory
to make a good argument.
I will look up the
authority that is relevant.
The idea that this guy would
be a cracker jack associate
simply on the basis of
reading a bunch of law books
makes no sense and it's
why, realistically,
he needs to ask for help from
people who have experience
because they're the ones that can help him
because they've been in the trenches
on this kind of stuff.
So, it's good of him to ask for help.
That's what a junior associate should do
but he's not gonna be a good attorney
just on the basis of having a good memory.
- Okay, you're asking
to look at private files
without any evidence of your assertion.
- Yeah, but the only way
that we can find the evidence
is to look at those files.
- It's a rickety argument.
- But is there precedent?
- Oh my God this is such
a stupid discovery battle.
Discovery allows you to get
evidence from the other side
and you don't have to
make a positive showing
in order to get that evidence as long as
you can demonstrate that the evidence
that you could potentially get is related
to the allegations that
you've made in your complaint
or are related to
defeating those allegations
or are relevant to your
defense in the case
then you should be able
to get that information.
You know, bounded by
things like privilege.
You can't get things that
are necessarily privileged
or trade secrets or things like that,
but if there was a rule that
said you had to have evidence
before you can get
evidence well no lawsuits
would ever happen so this is,
this is a stupid argument
that they're dealing with.
This is not the kind of discovery dispute
that you're gonna deal
with as an attorney.
- I'd like to think
Herman would come to me
before it even got to an investigation.
- I saw that, that should be stricken.
- Well, what if Herman did
come to you, your honor?
- There's nothing to strike.
There's nothing on the record.
(laughs)
- By firing him under false pretenses.
- You really think that little of me?
- I wouldn't trust you
as far as I can throw you, your honor.
- Hand over the files today, that's it.
- It's a little ridiculous
to hand over the files today.
Usually you would have several
weeks to go over the files
and then turn them over.
You have to be able to review
them before you turn them over
to the other side.
You have to check for
things like relevance.
You don't just get access
to millions of pages
of documents just by requesting them.
But this whole dispute is kind of insane.
Every civil case goes through
what's called, discovery.
It's the process by which
you ask the other side
for information and the other
side has to turn that over
unless they can show that
there's a reason not to.
Sometimes that reason is
because it's privileged,
sometimes that reason is
because it's not related
to the lawsuit.
And even if they were able
to get that information
it wouldn't relate to the
claims that they're making?
But you always have to
engage in some discovery
and it seems like this
company is just saying,
you have filed a sexual harassment claim
against our company and
you should not be entitled
to any documents whatsoever.
Well, as you can imagine,
that doesn't fly.
You always need some
documents and the company
that is the defendant
is going to be the one
who possesses those documents.
This is a dispute that would never happen.
- [Rachel] They're trying
to bury you in paperwork.
- [Mike] Well, they picked the wrong guy.
- If they didn't, I did. Get
it done by the end of the week.
I gotta run and charm a new client.
- Yeah, so this is a tactic
that actually happens.
You often seen big companies
try to bury the other side
in paperwork, especially
if they're going up
against a small firm
or a solo practitioner
that doesn't have the
infrastructure to be able
to review all of these documents.
However, any major law firm,
and this appears to be a major
law firm in this TV show,
has in-house document review systems
and what they allow you to do is to scan
thousands and sometimes
millions of pages of paperwork
and to run word searches on it.
Not to mention this kind of tactic
of trying to bury the
other side in paperwork
is highly disfavored by
federal and state courts.
And if a party tried to do this to me
and give me a huge dump of paper files
I would turn around and
go straight to the judge
and say, this is ridiculous,
they're trying to drive up our costs
and ask them to give it
to me in electronic form.
Or if I couldn't do that
then demand that the court
give me a court order
ordering them to turn
it over in electronic.
- Two months later I was fired
for having a bad attitude.
- This is ridiculous.
- Wipe that smirk off your face.
You're not even supposed to be here.
- You really don't want
that guy in the room
during this deposition.
No good can come from that.
- After working for Devlin Macgregor
you then went on to
waitress at Hooters, right?
- Yes, I did.
- A place that advertises the sexuality
of its wait staff, correct?
- You'll have to ask them that.
- I'm asking you.
- And she's not answering.
- Alright, this is good.
This is actually what a
deposition looks like.
You sit in a conference table.
You've got attorneys on either side.
Sometimes you have a party representative
and you have a stenographer
who's taking down
everything that's said
for the official record.
So this is a fairly
accurate representation
of what a big firm deposition looks like.
- I'm sorry, you were
arrested in your past
and you lied about it here under oath.
Is that making it seem
different than what it is?
No answer, alright.
- At this point Harvey and Mike
should be objecting like hell,
they should be instructing
the witness not to answer
and they should be
chastising the other attorney
for bringing up this subject
which was a criminal
matter when she was a minor
but also was under seal.
How did this guy even
get that information?
I don't know the rule with respect
to whether or not she can be found liable
for perjury in this particular context
when the subject was sort
of off limits to begin with
but all of this is wrong.
They should be up in arms,
they should be shutting
this deposition down.
None of this should be on
the record at this point.
- You can save your breath.
There's no way I'm testifying
at the hearing tomorrow.
- That's not why I'm here.
I know what you did.
- What are you talking about?
- You never worked for Devlin Macgregor.
And you were never harassed by Mr. Hunt.
- That's a lie.
- Look, I can tell you that
I've got the canceled checks
or the wire transfer
- this doesn't make any sense.
Okay, here's why this
doesn't make any sense.
They're hinting that the other side
hired a witness to
testify that the defendant
sexually harassed her in
some sort of quid pro quo
sexual harassment, and then
she was going to basically
purger herself and admit
to not being truthful
about a prior crime when she was 17.
That doesn't make any
sense because her testimony
is still on the record.
She testified that he
sexually harassed her.
So they hired someone
to provide evidence for the other side.
Now true, they might have
to deal with the fallout
of her being shown to be not
the most trustworthy person
but that testimony is still on the record.
They hired someone, they paid someone,
to give horrible testimony
about the defendant.
They're not even witness
tampering right, it's crazy.
- Wire transfer from your
account to Joanna Webster's.
Phone records with Joanna
Webster prior to her testimony.
And an affidavit stating
you paid Miss. Webster
to falsely testify.
- But, again, she falsely testified
against the people that hired her.
That's not even the way
you'd wanna witness tamper.
They paid someone to give
testimony against themselves.
It's totally insane.
- What do you want?
- An admission of guilt
and a guarantee that
you'll obtain treatment
before working again.
- Again, there's nothing
for him to admit guilt for,
except maybe witness
tampering if that is an actual
criminal crime.
This is a civil case
for sexual harassment,
quid pro quo sexual harassment
and he needs to pay the plaintiff money
and there might be an
admission of liability
but the most important thing
is that he's gonna compensate her
for the wrongs that she's done.
That's how the civil system works.
You put people in jail
to punish them for crimes
against really the state,
and the people in general.
You are civilly liable for things
that you've done to an individual.
In this case, sexual harassment.
- [Judge] All rise.
- That was Suits, episode one.
A lot of things going on there,
a lot of moving pieces.
So how does it stack up
against the real world?
What grade does it get?
Well, let's see.
In terms of the recruiting
process in law school
that it gets spot on.
And there was a lot of
brilliant legal arguing
marred only by the fact
that every single one
of those attorneys
would've been disbarred.
So all and all I give it a B minus.
They get some things right but
a lot of the legal argument
is wrong and all of those
attorneys would've been disbarred.
So, if you like this
video please subscribe
for more legal analysis and
I put together a playlist
with all of the legal reacts series.
If you like this video
you'll love the other videos
on A Few Good Men, My
Cousin Vinny, Law and Order.
So click on the playlist and I'll see you
in the next video.